bonsoir début d'un très long weekend
pour ces fêtes de la toussin des
bouchons presque incroyables sur toutes
les routes à la sortie des grandes
villes une météo de circonstances un
temps tout gris nous allons y revenir
comme nous reparlerons aussi au cours de
ce journal les otages français du
Polissario de la fête à Paris du
Mouvement des Jeunes giscardien de la
bête des vauges qui continue à faire des
siennes de la fin du Synode des évêques
à Rome mais mais avant de passer au
détails de toutes ces informations nous
allons vous parler de Janus 4 en France
on n pas encore d'astronautes mais on a
des plongeurs et quel plongeur ils
viennent de réussir une performance
extraordinaire au large de cavalère le
record du monde de travail en profondeur
les plongeurs de la Comex et du gismer
de la Marine nationale ont réussi une
sortie sous la mer à - 51 m exploit
sportif technique aussi qui a demandé
près de 10 années d'efforts des
entraînement à non plus finir des
contrôles et les expériences
scientifiques un travail en fait qui a
ressemblé à bien des points à celui des
astronautes et à celui des ingénieurs
qui les ont entourés les plongeurs sont
remontés cet après-midi nous les avons
d'ailleurs avec nous en direct de
Marseille ce soir nous avons deux des
recordman du monde donc Jacques verpa de
la Comex et Gérard Vial premier maître
dans la Marine nationale vous êtes avec
nous donc
ououiou d'abord je vous félicite puisque
vous avez été décoré cet après-midi à
votre sortie des engins et ma première
question est toute simple et toute bête
pour un profan expliquez-nous pourquoi
vous êtes descendu à Mo- 501
m
pourquoi pour prouver qu'on pouvait le
faire voilà entre autres oui il fallait
prouver que on était capable de
travailler à des des profondeurs tell
pour pour développer d'abord pour les
les les clients éventuels qui sont les
pétroliers et puis bon ben il y a pas
que les pétroliers par la suite il y
aura plus tard
des des des marchés certainement qui
s'ouvriront puisque il y a pas mal de de
surfaces sous la mer qui sont apporté de
la main et c'est c'est toutes ces
surfaces
sont contiennent bon ben du minerai du
du pétrole et tout ça bon ben il est
important pour nous justement de de
pouvoir atteindre ces ce pétrole ou ces
mineraiss et donc bon ben il est
important de descendre de plus en plus
profond Gérard Vial il y a eu un
accident le 18 octobre une panne de
courant sur le bateau qui qui vous
alimentait comment ça s'est passé au
fond bah en fait nous on n' pas eu le
temps de de de de réfléchir ni d'avoir
peur ou quoi que ce soit puisque Jacques
venait de de rentrer de de sa plongée il
était sorti donc à euh pendant 10
minutes à peu près un Jacques oui oui à
peu près non non la première plongée non
une demi-heure une demi heure oui et
puis bon ben Jacques la sortie de en
rentrant de sa plonger rentré dans la
tourelle on l'a déséquipé et puis
blackout et puis bon ben blackout plus
d'électricité plus de laison avec la
surface bon ben à ce moment-là on a
fermé les panneaux on a fermé les
panneaux la tourelle pour nous isoler de
la de de la mer donc et puis bon nous
étions en pression dans la tourelle puis
on a attendu que ça se passe vous n'avez
pas eu peur oh ben on n pas le temps
vous étiez entraîné par exemple à ce
genre d'accident bon ben t tous les
plongeurs qui ont participé à cette à
cette plongée bon sont des plongeurs qui
ont quand même un minimum d'expérience
et puis bon ben ça ce sont des choses
qui arrivent c'est techniquement c'est
pas c'est pas une catastrophe c'est
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment quelque
chose de tout à fait pas naturel mais
enfin ça arrive quoi est-ce qu'il y a eu
déjà des accidents graves avec ce genre
de plongé
non je P ça m personnellement ça m'est
difficile de répondre parce que j'ai pas
de statistiqu en fait je suis plongeur
de la Marine nationale et puis bon ben
dans le domaine industriel je j'ai pas
tellement de de compéten pour en parler
mais en fait je crois que la plupart des
des des accidents qui ont lieu bon de
plongeur les accidents de plongeur ne
sont pas dus directement à la plongée
mais duû au matériel aux conditions de
la de la mer
ou ou ou autre quoi mais pas pas
directement à la plongée c'est-à-dire
l'accident de plongée décompression
vraiment le l'accident décompression
type ou l'accident de plongée type ne
fait pas de mort enfin à ma connaissance
j'en ai jamais entendu parler quoi enfin
dans le domaine industriel ou de la
plongée sérieuse vous êtescendu donc à
-501 M c'estàdire une pression qui est
quelque chose comme 50 fois supérieure à
la pression normale est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment travailler efficacement à - 500
m je veux dire est-ce que vous
travaillez vraiment dans de bonnes
condition avec du matériel approprié
voilà parce que que on fait pas les
mêmes efforts qu'à 10 m on est obligé de
se surveiller de faire très attention à
ce qu'on fait donc il faut disons du
matériel qui démultiplie X fois enfin
plutôt beaucoup chaque effort on a
raison ou non de vous de vous comparer à
des astronaute
oui en quelque sorte oui c'est un peu ça
on est dans un milieu hostile quoi bon
ben
évidemment on vit d'une façon
artificielle on nous fait vivre d'une
façon artificielle c'est certain dans
dans ce sens-là ça rejoint un peu la la
vie des astronaut ou le travail des des
astronautes quoi et physiologiquement
pour disons pour l'avenir on n'ait pas
peur que que ça ait des conséquences sur
votre corps par exemple ben pour ça on
fait confiance au médecins qui nous
assure que non VO ça la plongée d'essais
hein c'est c'est ça comporte quelques
risques de toute façon c'est un métier
tout neuf finalement la planée profonde
ou la Plée en général industrielle bon
ben il faut bien y aller il y a des gens
qui ont commencé à voler dans l'aviation
il y a des gens qui ont commencé il y a
des gens qui ont dans tous les domaines
il faut commencer bon ben si on commence
à se poser les questions qu'est-ce qui
arrivera après qu'est-ce qui va alors on
fait plus rien quoi c'est fini quoi il
faut y aller quoi bien félicitations
encore
501 m un record du
monde l'affaire des Français enlevé par
le Polissario maintenant monsieur guide
comin l'ambassadeur de France à Alger
reçu hier matin par le Président de la
République Monsieur Valéri jiscard
desestin a été chargé par le chef de
l'État de transmettre un message
personnel au président de la République
Algérienne monsieur bouédien et les
contacts diplomatique entre les deux
pays se poursuivent d'ailleurs ce soir
l'ambassadeur de France à Alger a été
convoqué au ministère des Affaires
étrangères et on lui a demandé le sens
et la portée des récentes initiatives et
déclarations faites à Paris à propos de
cette affaire parmi ces initiatives il y
a la décision du ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur Bonet d'expulser de France h
militants du Front Polissario cinq
d'entre eux interpellé à Paris ce matin
ont déjà quitté d'ailleurs le territoire
français ils ont demandé à partir pour
l'Algérie à en croire la presse
algérienne le climat est loin d'être au
beau fixe entre Algers et Paris elle
parle d'hystérie des mass médias
M Jid critique la campagne
anti-algérienne qui se développe en
France une croisade dit même le
quotidien algérien les autorités elles
semblent plus conciliantes nous sommes
prêts à vous aider pour des contacts dis
disait hier monsieur bjaoui apparemment
les avocats des six Français en enlevés
à Zerat n'ont pas attendu cette
déclaration pour essayer d'avoir des
nouvelles de leurs clients ils sont
partis pour Alger où ils vont rencontrer
les responsables du front poissario
avant de prendre l'avion Jacques Michel
a expliqué comment ces contacts ont été
pris cette démarche est une démarche
publique puisqueencore une fois nous
avons le 25 octobre envoyé un télégramme
au front Polissario et que le front
Polissario de son côté par
l'intermédiaire de l'agence de presse
algérienne agence Presse Service a
répondu à l'appel qui avait été lancé au
front poissario et je cite les propos du
secrétaire général de ce front euh le
front poissario est disposé à entrer en
contact avec toute personne luttant pour
la justice et le droit des peuples qui
espérez-vous rencontrer à ALG nous
espérons rencontrer des représentants
qualifiés du du front pocario et Michel
Bloom et
moi-même
avons espéré que ce que de cette
acceptation de dialogue officiel de la
part du front Polissario sortirait
quelque chose est-ce que les l'expulsion
des h membres du Polissario de France ce
matin va vous compliquer la tâche
écoutez pour moi
essentiellement il s'agit d'un drame
humain nous allons à Alger pour avoir
des nouvelles des cisotages et pour
savoir pour avoir une réponse à la
question que tout le monde se pose
savoir s'ils sont vivants s'ils sont en
bonne santé et nous espérons pouvoir
rapporter des nouvelles à leur famille
au minimum et pour les autres otages
bien entendu nous poserons la question
voilà et puis toujours à propos de cette
affaire des Français enlevés par le
poissario la Libye s dit prête à
faciliter les
contacts nouveau détournement d'avion
aujourd'hui cela s'est passé dans le
Sud-Est asiatique cette fois et puis
chose étonnante il s'agit d'un avion
vietnamien deux victimes au cours de ce
détournement deux officiels vietnamiens
tués par les pirates de l'air par contre
les 36 passagers ont été libérés ce soir
sur l'aéroport de Singapour les quatre
pirates ont été arrêtés on ne sait pas
pour l'instant pourquoi ils ont détourné
cet avion Amsterdam les téléphones
sonnent dans les diverses rédactions des
journaux hollandais souvent une voix au
bout du fil explique c'est nous qui
avons enlevé monsieur Caranza l'homme
d'affaires hier matin il y a beaucoup
trop d'appels dit la police on ne peut
pas tous les prendre au sérieux même
lorsqu'ils prétendent comme cela s'est
passé ce matin encore parler au nom de
la Fraction Armée Rouge certains ont
même réclamé la libération d'un
terroriste allemand emprisonné en
Hollande en fait le gouvernement et la
police ne savent pas trop quoi faire ils
cherchent et ils fouillent pour
l'instant sans
résultat et puis 12 jours après
l'annonce de la mort d'ans Martine
schleer la chasse à l'homme continue en
Allemagne de l'Ouest sans résultat là
aussi aucune trace ou presque des 6 des
16 plutôt des 16 extrémistes recherchés
près de 800000 contrôles ont déjà été
effectués 309 arrestations et
officiellement rien de nouveau pour la
police les extrémistes doivent
maintenant être hors des frontières
d'Allemagne alors évidemment les yeux se
tournent vers la France vers la région
de mulouse où l'on a retrouvé le corps
de Monsieur schleer Gérard inet a suivi
pour nous les contrôles de police
effectués dans la région pendant une
journée ce jour-là les policiers à
l'évidence abandonnent les recherches à
la frontière tant il est facile de
passer d'un poste à un autre vous venez
de passer la frontière entre la France
et la Suisse il y a jamais de contrôle
du côté français non non jamais contrôle
presque moins j'ai jamais vu
personne d'autant plus facile que si les
terroristes avaient eu un quelconque
doute à la frontière ils auraient pu
emprunter comme nous les nombreux
chemins forestiers qui séparent la
France de la
Suisse mais ce jour-là vraiment il ne se
souci plus de la frontière ce qui les
intéresse c'est l'endroit où Hans Martin
Schleyer a été séquestré et peut-être
assassiné avant de fouiller la région et
les cMAT de la ligne magino ils ont dû
vérifier systématiquement les 2000
appels téléphoniques vérifiez les
témoignages de la population même celui
du pompiste qui prétendait avoir vu
l'eau diverte où circulaient les
ravisseurs de Hans Martin
Schleyer rien et pourtant les policiers
semblent avoir àquis la certitude que le
patron des patrons allemands a été
détenu dans le sud de
l'Alsace et ce jour-là dès 9h les
gendarmes fouillent les abords de la
ferme
AW
VO nous venons de contrôler le blocos
numéro
439 le 439 devant la ferme
ARB bonjour monsieur bonjour ça va au
travail ouais vous tombez bien là on est
en train de fouiller les blocos dans la
région vous n'auriez pas vu quelqu'un
de particulier ces derniers jours ces 8
derniers
jours un travail de fourmis mais jusqu'à
maintenant toutes ces vérifications
n'ont rien apportter si ce n'est des
visites systématiques aujourd'hui dans
les villas du quartier résidentiel de
mulouse réunion politique ce weekend le
congrès des élus socialistes et
républicains à villeorbane dans la
banlieue lyonnaise 600 délégués
assistent à cette réunion dont le temps
fort sera dimanche le discours prononcé
par François miteran Charles Hernu ce
matin a souligné que c'est à partir des
communes que va se livrer l'assaut
contre la droite et puis la politique la
politique et la fête ce weekend aussi
pour le Mouvement des Jeunes giscardiens
baptisés autrement 2500 jeunes venus de
toute la France qui étaient là à Paris
donc pour se distraire pour parler et
puis aussi pour écouter Jean-Pierre
Soisson le secrétaire général du parti
républicain qui leur a soumis trois
mesures propres à faciliter leur premier
emploi 1 il faut revaloriser le travail
manuel 2 les universités et les grandes
écoles devront passer avec les
professions et l'état des contrats de
débouché 3 il faut prévoir des prêts
longue durée pour les étudiants les
jeunes giscardiens ont évidemment bien
accueilli ces propositions autrement
répète-t-il n'est pas un parti c'est un
mouvement pour changer la vie
quotidienne des jeunes avec les jeunes
l'objectif d'Autrement est de montrer
aux 4 millions de jeunes de 18 à 23 ans
qu'il existe dans la majorité
présidentielle des jeunes qui partagent
leurs préoccupations et qui tentent de
trouver des solutions concrètes à leur
difficultés à tous ces garçons et à
toutes ces filles qui ont participé à
cette première fête les militants
giscardiens ont dit un chômeur sur deux
à moins de 25 ans ou bien encore 9 % des
jeunes se droguent ce n'est pas normal
c'est donc pour changer tout cela que
les jeunes ont débattu toute la journée
sur les problèmes du premier emploi du
sport et du service militaire plusieurs
ministres et secrétaire d'État comme
Christian BELAC René Aby Michel dornano
et Alice Sony CIT ont écouté les crit et
enreistr les espoirs cette caution
gouvernementale ne gêne pas les
animateurs d'Autrement bien au contraire
car ils veulent prouver qu'être
giscardien ce n'est pas une
honte vous savez que les jeunes sont
relativement dégûé de la politique parce
qu'ils ont le sentiment et le sentiment
justifié que la politique traditionnelle
ne leur apporte rien dans leur vie
quotidienne nous avons déjà obtenu un
certain nombre de résultats je vous
donne quelques exemples al CIT par
exemple présentera gouvernement sur
notre proposition un projet qui
permettra aux étudiants non licenciés de
bénéficier d'un scis supplémentaire
jusqu'à leur licence c'est une mesure
qui touche plusieurs dizaines dizaines
et peut-être centaines de milliers
d'étudiants autre exemple notre
participation à l'association pour le
premier emploi où nous avons déjà dans
10 départements test trouvé des
centaines d'emplois à de jeunes chômeurs
pourquoi avez- vous choisi de participer
ou travailler dans un mouvement
giscardien parce que je pense que le
gros problème des jeunes c'est de pas
faire de politique politicienne
autrement dit il faut prendre les choses
tout à fait au sérieux à tous les
niveaux et tenter de de s'extraire un
peu de de la du rituel pour tenter de
faire quelque chose d'original de
quelque chose de nouveau et que
trouvez-vous dans un mouvement comme
celui-là que vous ne trouvez pas dans
les autres mouvements de jeunes ou dans
les autres partis politiques spontanéité
certaine Monsieur et Madame Lambert
viennent de perdre leurs huit moutons
leurs huit bêtes sont mortes la nuit
dernière une information qui ne va pas
bouleverser la face du monde bien sûr
sauf si j'ajoute c'est la bête des vuges
qui est responsable alors là évidemment
ça change tout cette bête qui existe les
gendarmes le confirment qui est
impressionnante par sa taille on a
retrouvé ses traces cette bête a réussi
ce que bien peu d'animaux ou d'hommes
parviennent à faire devenir un mythe
créer une légende alors qu'elle est
encore
vivante
elle est là tapis au fond de la
forêt depuis 6 mois elle a fait de la
commune de La Bresse son terrain de
chasse égorgeant chèvres et moutons elle
descend de la montagne avec la tombée de
la nuit rodant au milieu des fermes et
des premières maisons
elle semble tuer par plaisir déjà 150
victimes j'ai allumé mon projecteur et
c'est là que j'ai eu aperçu une chèvre
au coin du parc àolet les autres
n'étaient plus là alors j'allume plus
bas deux yeux qui brillaient alors tout
de suite je ça y est voilà dévches qu
j'ai peur de la B je ne sors plus la
nuit pourquoi qu'est-ce que vous priez
quand il y a plus de troupeau si la FA
elle peut s'attaquer au aux personnes
elle l'a pas fait quand même non l'a
encore pas fait jusqu'à présent
maintenant
onarm puis on bruit benien on après
maintenant oui c'est déjà une bête
énorme une grosse bête he qui puisse
laisser une empreinte de 12 12 cm et dem
sur 8 en tout cas ce n'est pas une
histoire c'est cette bête existe
réellement cette bête existe vous le
confirmez oui oui je confirme s'il
viennent en France il peutvent venir que
de l'Est des pay des pays de l'Est oui
mais je ne pense pas qu'il viennent de
là-bas que cet animal là vienne de
là-bas il viendrait d'où alors à votre
avis où il a certainement été lâché dans
le massif de ramber Villet
volontairement
involontairement les premiers à réagir
ont été les chasseurs une quarantaine de
Gaillard pasich de leur peine toujours
prês au rondes de nuit au affu au sommet
des arbres au battu Collectiv qui n'ont
fait comme victime jusqu'à prés un chat
de chiens et c'est le comble un
mouton nous fait courir
B déjouer à ce moment on a l'impression
d'être vraiment petit à côté est plus
forte que
vous bte d'un
partous m
elle a été tiré souvent 32 fois jamais
l' il résoudre à rentrer les troupeaux
la
nuitalléser
mout brout au milieu des Barbel des
pièges la mairie et les autorités sont
intervenu à leur tour avec un plan
d'attaque intercommunale un système
d'alarme et la promesse du concours de
l'armée de la gendarmerie les jours de
la bête sont
compé je
considère que tous les moyens doivent
être mis en uvre à partir de maintenant
pour mettre fin à cette
bête
on ignorait qu'une commune française
replongeait dans la nuit des temps par
la simple présence d'un animal pouvait
réagir avec autant d'énergie et de
cohésion cela prouve bien que pour unir
les hommes rien ne vaut encore la peur
du
loup
en Chine populaire 10 personnes ont été
condamnées à mort et exécutées récemment
à Pékin c'est une affiche officielle
signée du tribunal populaire de la ville
qui l'a révélé ces peines ont été
prononcées pour assassinat ou crime en
Espagne à la demande de la gauche et des
mouvements féministes le gouvernement va
proposer aux députés une loi pour que
l'adultère et le concubinage ne soi plus
des délit le code pénal actuel espagnol
prévoit 6 ans de prison lorsqu'une femme
ou un mari trompe son
conjoint fin cet après-midi à Rome du 5è
Synode des évêques il s'est terminé
après un mois de travaux placés sous le
signe de la
sérénité qui n'a pas été n pas été le
cas pour les syes précéd à vra le sujet
C anné à savoir la catéchèse c'estàd
l'enseignement de la foi chrétienne se
prêta pas beaucoup à la
polémique PA pour concl les travx lancé
cet après-midi un app un appel en faveur
de la liberté
religieuse
le synode de Rome 1977 c'est donc fini
la place Saint-Pierre va retrouver son
rythme habituel de touristes et de
pèlerins et les gardes suisses
n'offriront plus leur salut aux 250
évêques et supérieurs d'ordre religieux
qui vont retourner dans leurs continents
respectifs avec dans la tête et les
valises des centaines d'idées nouvelles
concernant la catéchèse c'est-à-dire la
transmission de la foi on l'a déjà
souligné le synode n'a pas soulevé de
grandes vagues le sujet était vaste et
complexe des interventions remarquées
d'évêques du tiersmonde et des pays
socialistes auront certainement
contribué à réveiller quelques prélat
qui ne croyaient pas encore tout à fait
que la crise imposerait non quelques
arrangements de détail mais une
imagination tous asimé le pape qui a
participé malgré sa fatigue à la plus
grande partie des sciences du Synod
confirmera probablement cette
orientation positive des évêques du
monde ce qui m'a frappe peut-être cette
fois-ci plus que pour les autres synodes
c'est que les évêques de certains pays
où le droit à la catéchèse est menacés
voire même souvent méconnus et attaqués
bien ces évecsl ont parlé avec une
grande liberté d'expression avec force
avec courage même je pense à telle ou
telle intervention d'évêqu de pays où
peut-être ne soupçonnait pas que
l'église était encore
persécutée église persécuter ou pas il
faudra plus que des efforts de rédaction
de catéchisme pour faire opérer aux
jeunes un retour vers la religion les
évêques français présents au synode
l'ont souligné ce sont tous les
chrétiens qui doivent maintenant se
sentir responsabl de l'avenir de la foi
et donc de la
catéchèse bien certain que pour nous en
France le problème de la catéchèse se
pose très fortement et en particulier à
la prochaine assemblée de lourd il en
sera question comme il en a été question
déjà en 75 76 mais cette fois nous
aurons à approfondir certainement cette
question et suivant ce qui a été vu déjà
au synode à trouvé un enracinement plus
profond de la foi car les jeunes
aujourd'hui ont besoin d'être plus
enracinés que nous ne l'étions et
deuxièmement deuxièmement de trouver des
moyens d'accès nouveaux pour la foi des
jeunes en les connaissant bien alogant
avec eu les fêtes de la toussin comme
chaque année c'est un moment particulier
pour penser à la mort c'est le temps du
souvenir pour la plupart d'entre nous
mercredi prochain à 20h30 sur Antenne 2
dans notre magazine question de temps
Jean-Pierre elcabache Louis berillot et
toute l'équipe d'Antenne 2 parleront de
la mort il y aura plusieurs reportages
des interviews des témoignages et puis
aussi l'analyse d'un sondage effectué
par la sofrress pour le compte d'Antenne
2 sur le thème les Français face à la
mort un sondage publié par le Nouvel
Observateur et Don voici les principaux
résultats vous arri-t-il de penser à la
mort oui souvent dit un français sur C
quelquefois rarement répond la majorité
jamais à vous 20 % des Français c'est en
tout cas une préoccupation plus grande
pour les femmes que pour les
hommes cependant à laatoussin quatre
Français sur C changent leurs habitudes
soit en ayant une pensée pour leur mort
soit en se rendant sur leur tombe soit
en allant spécialement à la
messe y a-t-il quelque chose après la
mort oui mais pour un Français sur deux
seulement et la plupart ne savent pas
exactement quoi seul 19 % croi en une
autre vie fait surprenant un catholique
sur quatre pratiquant occasionnellement
croit qu'il n'y a rien après la
mort à la quasi unanimité les personnes
interrogées pensent qu'il ne faut pas
cacher la mort aux enfants qu'il faut la
leur apprendre mais que c'est davantage
le rôle de la famille que de
l'école la la majorité des Français
revendique le droit de pouvoir mourir en
refusant des soins mais cette
revendication s'estompe avec l'âge en
revanche c'est surtout à 18 ans que l'on
a envie d'être
immortel bien Martine la RAU vous avez
étudié en détail tous ces chiffres
qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus frapper je
dirais d'abord le fait que le sondage a
eu lieu je vous signale que c'est le
premier sondage aussi complet sur un
sujet hierur encore tabou les Français
parlent de la mort ça c'est un point
important deuxièmement ce sont les
contradictions des Français ils veulent
bien en parler mais ils y pensent peu
ils veulent l'apprendre la réhabiliter
mais surtout aussi l'exclure il faut
l'avouer nettement et puis il y a des
faits de société vraiment des faits de
société la mort pour l'agriculteur et le
cadre supérieur ce n'est plus la même
mort au travers des sondages je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails mais vraiment
c'est très différent et puis il y a un
exemple quand même c'est celui de la
toussin vous apercevez que 58 % des gens
av vous se rendre sur les tombes changer
leurs habitudes 80 % mais que 42 %
pensent au morts alors qu'est-ce qu'ils
font ils vont en weekend c'est ça la
société et et la religion alors alors la
religion et bien ça na plus à supporter
la mort alors ça c'est quandme une
découverte parce qu'on avait
l'impression que la religion c'était un
passage commode et puis on découvre
aussi des catholiques qui ne croient
plus à l'au-delà et ça aussi c'est
surprenant et l'attitude à l'égard des
enfants alors là je vais pas vous en
dire long parce que nous avons un
magazine mercredi nous avons un long
passage sur les enfants sains et la mort
je peux vous dire simplement que entre
ce que disent les adultes et ce que
pensent les enfants il y a un fossé
alors je crois que les adultes
voudraient dire la mort aux enfants leur
apprendre et que dans la pratique c'est
très très très différent vous le verrez
mercredi ouis nous reviendrons
d'ailleurs donc mercredi dans question
de temps sur ce sondage en détail mais
où en êes-vous dans la préparation de ce
magazine Magazine il est presque prêt
maintenant mais ça a été passionnant
passionnant à suivre je vous assure je
n'ai jamais rien vu de d'aussi terrible
on a une série de reportages on veut
démitifier la mort nous avons des
témoignages forts rien d'insupportable à
la vue je tiens à le dire car c'est une
heure de grande écoute on voudrait que
la mort en 77 ce soit vraiment la mort
des Français la mort telle qu'il
l'envisage la mort obligatoire mais sans
drame alors je crois que ça ne laissera
personne indifférent j'en j'en fais le
serment après l'avoir vu tout le monde
saura ce que c'est que la mor
77 bien rendez-vous donc 20h30 question
de temps sur Antenne 2 euh dans la
situation sociale grve du personnel
navigant d'Air France le 1er novembre
prochain otess et stewward du syndicat
national du personnel navigant
commercial vont cesser le travail
pendant 24 he la direction indique
qu'elle assurera quand même la totalité
des vols long courriers et 30 % des vols
moyen courriers les pêcheurs de Haran
ont levé ce matin le blocus du port de
Boulogne ils ont pris cette décision
après avoir reçu l'assurance que le
march marché commun n'interviendrait pas
à propos de ce poisson avant le mois
prochain et puis au casino de divon
lesbin la nuit dernière les gangster ont
fait sauter la banque pas en joint bien
sûr mais avec des armes à la main un
holdup qui leur a rapporté 11000 francs
sport en rugby et All Black les joueurs
néo-zélandais ont failli perdre leur
auréol cet après-midi à Lyon une très
bonne sélection française les amis en
difficulté jusqu'au dernier moment
finalement le score final
10 à 12 les Français ont perdu les All
Black ont gagné la météo pour demain
dimanche sur la France demain les
brouillards matinaux seront nombreux et
localement denses après leur dissipation
le ciel sera assez ensoleillé sauf près
de la Manche ù les images ou les nuages
plutôt c'est très mal écrit le bultin de
la météorologie était très mal écrit ce
soir où les les nuages abondants
pourront être accompagnés de petites
pluies je vous retrouve vers 23h20 pour
la dernière édition du journal et je
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée sur
Antenne 2